all right so before uh i head out on a
brief break
i do want to touch on the fact that it
is august and that has some relevance
we're going to have some great guest
hosts coming up farron cousins will be
filling in for me jesse dollamore but
before i leave it is august and
supposedly donald trump is being
reinstated in august
um yesterday i spoke with my pillow guy
mike lindell who says it'll be august
maybe september it'll be the supreme
court probably but who knows
but to step step back for a second from
mike pillow
the real question many are asking is not
whether trump will be reinstated he
won't be reinstated
but whether his followers will become
violent when he doesn't get reinstated
and whether his followers will try to
stage a second insurrection
now yesterday we looked at clips of an
organization that says they're going
back to the capitol on september 18th
there are i think we can say
conservatively
millions of people like maybe it's not
tens of millions but it's certainly
millions of people followers of trump
who have been led to believe by any
number of others that donald trump will
be returning to the throne as it were
somehow this month or next month it
might be
through the supreme court it might be
through the generals of the military
doing something nebulous that we don't
understand
or it'll be because something
incriminating will come out and joe
biden will resign
and so will kamala harris which by the
way wouldn't make trump president right
i mean trump
is not part of the line of succession
right now or maybe they don't even know
how it's going to happen but they think
maybe it will
but it won't be happening and so then
what among the 50-plus
attendees that salon spoke with at cpac
and dallas
more than 40 percent said they believed
in august trump would be reinstated
somehow
what do they do when it doesn't happen
some law enforcement agencies are paying
attention
zachary patrizo writes in salon that
quote on july 13
bloomberg news reported that lindell's
theories are enough to put fbi director
christopher
wray and other top national security
officials on alert
for the risk that the former president's
most ardent supporters
might again resort to violence now we're
already seeing dates move around what
was once august 13th
now some people say will be august 21st
why
well august 21st trump will be speaking
at a rally
in culmin alabama one rumor
of new i guess you could call it a new
delusion is that trump will be
reinstated at that rally by who how it's
not exactly clear because it will never
happen
and the shifting of the date is very
much like the end of the world rapture
people i've interviewed some of these
people
there's always some date it doesn't
happen
so they shift the date they say oh we
misread the signals or
god changed his mind or something was
out of context
and then they come up with a new date i
don't know that it will
prevent the violence but it needs to be
somehow put in these people's minds that
trump just lost
it's an occam's razor the simplest
explanation is the one that applies
the election was certified joe biden was
the winner and he was sworn in
donald trump is not in the line of
succession if the president
goes then it goes to the vp and if the
vp goes bye-bye then it's the speaker of
the house and so on trump is not part of
that the last president is not part of
that
and some others are saying now very
directly
as i told you yesterday that it will be
september and they're going to the
capitol so
i think the risk for violence is real
for me is trump really getting
reinstated is not the right question
it's it's a silly question of course
he's not the real question is will there
be violence
and i'm worried that there will be uh
we'll pick up on that
much more in future shows and let's hope
it doesn't happen
one of our sponsors is blue blocks blue
light glasses
i've sometimes had issues falling asleep
at night eventually realize some of it
might be coming from the blue light
emitted by my phone and computer screens
peer-reviewed studies show blue light
can suppress the hormone
melatonin which can make it hard to fall
asleep because your
sleep rhythms are disturbed i've seen a
lot of improvement since i started using
blue light glasses from blue blocks most
companies make blue light glasses
in a mass-produced way with no quality
standards but blue blocks glasses are
made in actual
optics labs in their australian
headquarters
they have over 40 modern frames you can
choose from they have a prescription
version non-prescription
even reading glasses and for every pair
of glasses
blue block cells they give a pair of
reading glasses to someone in need
you'll get twenty percent off when you
go to blueblocks dot com slash pacman
the link is right underneath the video
and there's also free shipping
worldwide on orders over 115 dollars